chers amis bonjour bonjour à vous tous
les militants vous dit former le socle
de notre parti vous grâce à qui nous
avons toujours traversé toutes les
tempêtes toutes les difficultés
vous qui avez toujours été solides comme
des rocs et qui nous permettait peuvent
continuer à servir la france
merci à vous ça fait du bien de se
retrouver ensemble ça fait du bien de se
retrouver dans une ambiance d'amitié et
de convivialité
alors oui merci à vous
je pense que vous commencez à voir un
peu faim en plus ya pas de déjeuner mais
j'espère que ça va pas trop nalement
bétourné votre attention
mais je me rends compte que les discours
y en a peut-être trop alors moi je ne
suis pas venu pour vous faire un disque
et j'ai pas envie de parler d'ici alors
vous allez me permet pas voilà je
préfère parler directement avec vous je
préfère vous parler d'abord de vous vous
parler de nous vous parlez de la france
parce que c'est ça qui nous réunit c'est
cela ce qui nous motive c'est ce qui
nous dépasse et qui nous donne envie de
faire tant d'efforts je veux vous parler
de la france d'aujourd'hui de la france
de demain celle que nous allons
construire ensemble les républicains
étant à la pointe de l'action que nous
allons me veil
vous avez il ya quelques jours il y a
quelques jours je rentrais du moyen
orient
il faisait beau et mon avions survoler
la france et là je voyais je voyais ses
villes ses villages
je voyais ces réseaux ferroviaires et
ses réseaux re ok je voyais les champs
et les bois et je me disais oui la
france d'autres france est belle
et quand on leur en garde vue du ciel on
se rend compte combien elle a été
façonné par tous ceux qui dans les
générations passées nous ont précédés et
comment aujourd'hui elle est encore fait
parce qu'ils travaillent jour et nuit
pour permettre à notre pays d'être grand
et être fiers de la france croient dans
la france ça n'est ni une utopie ni une
nostalgie c'est au contraire être
conscient de ce que sont les réalités
les richesses
elle est naturelle tout est là tout est
là à une condition c'est que nous ayons
la volonté que nous ayons le bon sens
que nous ayons le réalisme que nous
ayons l'unité bref tout le contraire de
ce que sont les socialistes
oui la france est grande dans la
république la france est grande parce
qu'elle est unie et c'est pour ça que
nous voulons ni du front national qui
finalement se replie sur lui même et ne
nous promet que le destin que le déni
que le déclin ni des socialistes dont le
gouvernement aujourd'hui est en train de
montrer à travers son incompétence son
inconséquence et sa suffisance qu'il est
incapable d'agir pour la france
nous les républicains ce que nous
voulons pour la france c'est au
contraire que la france soit grande et
qu'elle porte un message dans le monde
nous avons ici tous les atouts pour
préparer la puissance de demain
nous avons tout ce dont le monde de
demain a besoin une agriculture france
perd au moment où il va falloir nourrir
de plus en plus d'hommes et de femmes
dans la sphère une technologie qui nous
permet de répondre à travers le spatial
à tous les besoins
nous avons la possibilité d'avancer dans
le domaine de la santé nous portons la
langue et la culture que 80 pays partage
et qui nous donne une véritable
puissance mais pour ça il faut sortir
des inconséquences du gouvernement
socialiste qui à force de faire le grand
écart est purement et simplement en
train de faire du contorsionnisme oui
nous
ont besoin d'une défense forte on ne
peut pas envoyer nos militaires pour
défendre les valeurs de la force et dans
le même temps diminué nos crédits on ne
peut pas avoir un langage soi-disant
européen et dans le même temps
écrasez les français et les entreprises
sous dépasse bien supérieure à celle de
tous les pays européens est soudé
réglementation oui il vaut changer
d'attitude
il faut changer de politique et c'est
cela ce que nous les républicains nous
voulons alors ensemble
ensemble nous allons réussir ensemble
nous allons travailler non seulement
pour construire l'avenir non seulement
pour peser dans le monde mais tout
simplement pour que la france soit
grande à l'image de ce qu'elle a
toujours été à l'image de son destin et
de sa vocation